so today I want to talk about this idea
of boosting your metabolism trying to
speed it up a lot of people with a slow
metabolism and in their mind they think
they need to just just speed it up and
so they're always looking for a pill to
do it or you know green tea extract or
chili pepper so they can speed up this
metabolic rate okay and then they find
it just doesn't work so when you consume
caffeine or coffee to try to speed it up
you're not stimulating your metabolism
you're stimulating your sympathetic
nervous system which is the flight or
fight mechanism that is not the way to
lose weight you're actually going to
gain weight by increasing that mechanism
because you raise cortisol and you'll
notice that you'll have it right in the
midsection right here green tea does
elevate the metabolism like in very
small amounts
it's very insignificant you're not going
to see a lot of weight come off just by
drinking green tea or consuming Chili
Peppers sometimes people have this idea
that Oh Chili Peppers it's gonna create
some heat in my body
and so I'm gonna burn the fat off the
fat is not melted off with heat that's
not the way it works there's a machine
in your mitochondria that uses the fuel
for energy but it doesn't do it through
just temperature okay or else we could
just sit in a sauna and melt the fat off
that's not gonna work or sometimes
people will say well if I you know I'll
eat more frequently to stimulate my
metabolism
well you're operating off the idea that
oh if I'm hungry I have more of an
appetite then my metabolism is high no
no no that means that your blood sugars
are low okay and you need to eat it
doesn't mean that your metabolism is
faster and it is true that if you eat it
will create a spike with insulin and
drop low blood sugar and then you'll
want to eat more you're just going to
raise insulin and get fatter so we have
the speed of the metabolism okay and
then we have the concept of what is
being burned okay
who cares if your metabolism is fast if
you're only burning up your sugar
Reserve and not tapping into the fat
reserve there's many things that slow
your metabolism the
two big ones are actually there's three
age getting older okay you get through
menopause so your metabolism slows down
you don't have as much growth hormone
things like that but also it's the
amount of diets that you have done in
the past let's say when you're younger
especially as a kid so if you were
overweight as a child and you had to do
multiple diets again and again involving
a low-calorie chances are you're gonna
have a very slow metabolism as an adult
or even if you gain weight in your late
teens or even early 20s or after the
pregnancy so you go on a diet you lose
weight initially weight comes back and
then you do a diet again and then it's
it's harder the next time and the third
time is even harder the fourth time it's
impossible so what happens is the
frequency of diets really mess up your
metabolism because your body just
adjusts to the lower amount of calories
so your body just compensates the big
one though is the having insulin
resistance so the chronic consumption of
carbs over a long period of time develop
so much insulin resistance and what that
means is you have your cells are
resisting insulin so it's going to make
more to compensate so it's the quantity
of insulin in your body that will
prevent your metabolism for working so
you're gonna have what like a certain
set point so maybe you can lose but you
can't ever get below a certain weight
like 160 or something you just can't get
below that well that's because we have
insulin resistance and that is why the
keto plan and in a minute fasting works
so well because it targets this right
here okay you can't necessarily undo age
okay you can't really get rid of the
past but you can fix this okay and that
is the gonna actually speed up your
metabolism by fixing a hormone that is
dominating a hormone that is suppressing
the ability to burn fat when insulin is
low you can burn fat when insulin is
high you burn sugar fuel okay and also
this is a very important point to what
fuel is being burned do you want to burn
sugar you want to burn fat the
in fact you need to go into ketosis
ketones come from fat burning okay so
why not just focus on doing ketosis
exclusively and not do any other program
because you're gonna actually focus on
the thing that you want is to lose
actual fat versus just weight loss okay
now if your thyroids involved of course
your metabolism is going to be slower as
well but usually thyroid is secondary to
high levels of estrogen or something
going on with the gallbladder or the
liver
okay stress we talked about that if you
increase stress you increase cortisol
that's gonna slow things down
many people have gained weight after a
stress event so there are things you can
do to extract stress I'm going to put
some links down below if you had a major
stress event I suggest that you watch
that video it's called the stress
webinar and you can undo some of that
old stress because it is accumulative in
the body growth hormone is increased
through high quality sleep intense
exercise and keeping your sugar low okay
with protein there's a certain amount of
portion of protein lot smaller than you
think actually it's between 16 and 32
percent of certain proteins and I'll do
a separate video on this are actually
used for repair of the body not
necessarily used for calories okay so
when you're considering calories in your
diet some of that portion of protein
should not be used because you're gonna
be using that as repair and that is fuel
so I'm gonna do a separate video on that
the point about protein is that you want
a moderate amount of protein you want a
high quality protein so you're getting
the maximum absorption of those amino
acids so it's not wasted we want protein
that usually comes in nature versus
protein powders like whey protein is
very lean protein and that can stimulate
the insulin and create issues so you
want protein that comes in nature like
sardines eggs
fish a high-quality grass-fed meat
things like that but a moderate amount
we don't want to go low on that but we
don't want to go high we want to go
right in the middle right there okay so
then we have fat
the thing about fat is on a keto plan we
go up with the fat because we go down
with the carbs it's totally okay to
consume fat as long as your carbs are
lower important things about fat is to
allow you to go longer without eating
it's called intermittent fasting and fat
also has a lot of nutrition for your
hormones there's going to be a point
once you have adapted to fat-burning
where you can start to cut your fat back
a little bit if you're plateaued forcing
your body to use up its reserves and not
the dietary fat that you're consuming so
we want to make some adjustments on that
I have a lot of videos on that I'll put
some links down below so anyway I wanted
to just to clear up this idea that you
can just stimulate your metabolism boost
it without fixing the underlying issues
that so many people have thanks for
watching hey before you go would you
mind putting a comment down below to
tell me what you think about this video